the opinion of a great many people
forget canada for a second forget
america's hat come back down to america
the the opinion of a great many people
is that
conservative
traditional
christian overwhelmingly americans who
don't want their way of life completely
upended who don't want their rights
suspended who don't want their
traditional liberties taken away
they can't be reasoned with
we can't be reasoned with we can't be
allowed to express our voice this is why
when we vote and we elect someone like
donald trump that's a threat to
democracy how the hell is it a threat to
democracy just because the people voted
for a guy
well no but they didn't vote for the
right guy they really shouldn't have
been allowed to vote in the first place
according to one texas middle middle
school teacher was just caught on camera
conservative christians
they just they just need to get coveted
and die
that's what's frustrating
little hard to hear what these cackling
hens are saying which says if if they
had just all given up their rights and
all taken the fauchiachi right away then
it would be over there would be no covet
but they haven't done they just need to
die these conservative christians so
sure this middle school teacher
i guess she didn't say it in the front
of a classroom
she just said it to other teachers and
administrators
but what do you think she's teaching
what do you think the kids are being
taught
they're being taught that if you
descend from this
regime
you deserve death you just need to go
away not there she's not even saying you
need to go to the gulag
man
stalin seems like a squish compared to
these ladies these ladies are a lot
tougher these these radicals in middle
schools and high schools and colleges
they would make stalin blush
not no they shouldn't even go to a
forced labor camp they should just die
that's what's got to happen i'm glad you
like that clip i like that clip too now
ring the bell subscribe you have to
subscribe you must do it that way you
will get notifications also
probably the better way to do it head on
over to apple podcast spotify stitcher
google play wherever you get your audio
podcasts
subscribe to the michael knowles show
leave a five star review we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]